зараз з нами на прямому зв'язку Сергій
шкарлет міністр освіти та науки України
пане Сергію наші вітання Вітаю вас Слава
Україні Героям слава пане Сергію ви
просили керівників навчальних закладів
перевезти навчання в онлайн формат поки
до 14 жовтня Скажіть будь ласка за яких
умов ця рекомендація може бути
продовжена і ця рекомендація вона
стосується її дитячих садочків
».»
не буду повторювати безпека наших дітей
безпека освітян на першому місці
А взагалі ви розглядаєте варіант
загального скасування очного навчання у
зв'язку з цими терористичними атаками
тому що Ну ми розуміємо що в багатьох
випадках батьків налякані за дітей все
одно не пускають їх до школи
ви знаєте я би не казав би про тотальну
заборону
взагалі очного
навчання різні території оскільки є
різна безпека у ситуації по нашій країні
нашій країні досить велика і
враховуючи і
територіальну локацію того чи іншого
закладу освіти знаходження його близько
Або поруч з деякими стратегічними
об'єктами керівники з військових
адміністрацій самостійно приймають
рішення щодо взагалі до оцінки безпеки і
формату освітнього процесу
хочу сказати моє особисте ну ставлення
до
онлайну освіти це може бути лише додаток
адже дитяче спілкування адже з можливі
спілкування побудови окремої освітньої
траєкторії між учнями вчителями воно не
замінять незаміниться спілкуванням через
екран але безпекова ситуація вимагає від
нас прийняття рішення в тому числі і про
продовження освіти шляхом її онлайн
формату оскільки дитина не може бути
відірвана від освітнього проце
А загалом щодо безпеки шкіл пане
сергійовичу вдалося вирішити проблеми з
укриттям у тих навчальних закладах які
станом на 1 вересня на початок
навчального року не змогли приймати у
себе учнів
ви знаєте на початок навчального року у
нас було десь
58-60% готовності закладів загальної
середньої освіти щодо безпекового
формату безпекових ситуацій наявності
укриттів і на 10-15 вересня ми
розраховували ще приблизно на 10%
збільшення так воно і сталося на
сьогодні ми маємо майже 70%
закладів загальної середньої освіти
тобто шкіл мають укриття які ДСНС
атестувало як такі що можна
запроваджувати освітні процеси в
повноформатному режимі в цілому в цілому
ми перевірили комісії за участю ДСНС
національної поліції
закладів військових військових
адміністрацій Міністерства освіти і
науки перевірили більше ніж 25 тисяч
об'єктів закладів освіти що становить
95%. і ми на сьогодні учно перевели з 25
000 16 419 закладів освіти має право
працювати скороченому форматі адже там
наявні укриття різного типу які
дозволяють організувати безпеку
освітнього процесу якщо взяти в цілому
зріст в Україні це приблизно 63%
готовності об'єктів освіти до безпечного
функціонування по сферах
69,4% готовності це саме школи
501%, це дитячий садочки
заклади профтехосвіти це 93% найбільших
готовності освіти і заклади фахової
передвищує вищої освіти тобто коледжу
університету приблизно 75%
пане Сергію У нас є ще один виклик це
холодиль для нашого навчального процесу
тобто навіть якщо діти таки підуть з
наступного тижня у школи наскільки наші
заклади освіти готові до настання
холодів і тим більше якщо якийсь час
діти будуть змушені проводити у підвалах
Дуже гарне запитання дуже
служить що Президент України Володимир
Зеленський і прем'єр-міністр України
адміністратором завжди
наголошували
постійно на готовності до зимового до
опалювального періоду набагато раніше
ніж цей період наступав ми вже
весни завжди починали готувати Саме так
сталося і навіть в цей рік рік
російської агресії і на сьогодні знову ж
таки повторююсь 25 тисяч закладів
об'єктів освіти на сьогодні було
перевірено з них
24,388
закладів освіти готові до опалювального
сезону що складає 90% від всіх закладів
на сьогодні на 100% готовність є в
декількох областях а саме в 8 областей
такі як Київська Вінницька Волинська
івано-франківська Рівненська Полтавська
Тернопільська та Чернівецька тут на 100%
заклад всі заклади освіти готові до
опалювального сезону і готовність шкіл
дитячих садочків на сьогодні теж на
досить пристойному вигляді і ми маємо
стримане повізм стосовно стосовно цього
опалювального сезону наприклад школи
готові на 92%. з них 11 областей готові
на 100% дитячі садочки готові на 92%, 13
областей готові на 100%. А ну ми чітко
розуміємо що деякі зворожих ракет На
жаль
пошкодить пошкодили наші Тез наші
електростанції в різних регіонах країни
але але і президент і уряд ставили
завдання що заклади освіти дитячі
садочки школи мають бути в пріоритеті по
забезпеченню їх типом до уваги батьків
також хотілося б цьому контексті
звернутися тому що не варто забувати що
ковід теж не відступив і
за рекомендаціями Діти повинні мають
бути вакциновані в тому числі та для
того щоб ми е-е безпечно всі пережили
цей холодний сезон хотів би наостанок
пана Сергію запитати про
вцілому систему онлайн навчання
наскільки воно зараз станом на зараз
налагоджене чи тому що це відточений
такий системний процес і технічно Це все
можна організувати чи можливо навпаки ви
скажете що є якісь проблеми учителів з
якими вони зіштовхуються в онлайн
навчанні дякую Дуже дякую вам за
запитання питання адже дійсно Ну
спочатку Кові до 20-й рік 21 рік ковід
навчив нас багато чому в застосуванні
онлайн-технологій навчання в освітньому
процесі Ми навіть після оцінки
20-го року оцінили падіння якості від
онлайн освіти зробили певні висновки
зробили певні допрацювання нашої онлайн
нашого технологій нашого онлайн навчання
ми створили нашу національну електронну
платформу всеукраїнська школа онлайн яка
за підтримки наших колег донорів
постійних постійних друзів в
Міністерства освіти і науки України і
України в цілому компанія юнісеф яка
допомагала дуже сильно допомагала
створити
наш контент цієї всеукраїнської школи
онлайн на сьогодні він налічує біля двох
з половиною тисяч вже відеоуроків тестів
матеріалів для самообробки ми
запровадили систему формування
індивідуальної траєкторії учня і вчителя
які на сьогодні дозволяє повернутись до
певних я більш більш слабо засвоєних тем
і підвищити якість в тому числі і освіти
на будь-якому етапі застосування онлайн
навчання а самі Такі ключові точки
Мабуть це
об'єктивно нашої внутрішнього
переміщення особи нашої викладачі наші
діти які на сьогодні іноді
лишаючи власну домівку не брали не те що
там засобів для навчання навіть
документів І на сьогодні ми працюємо
працюючи навіть з 24 лютого вже ми
отримали більше ніж 5 тисяч ноутбуків
Саме від компанії юнісеф більше ніж 50
000 крон хромбуків Це запланована
передати від компанії Google причому 10
тисяч вже в Україні
2000 нам планшетів від девайсів
закуповує на всеукраїнська громадське
всесвітня Не не урядова організація save
the children компанія Acer передала
декілька сотень ноутбуків спільно з
нашими друзями колегами міністерством це
цифрової трансформації Ми сьогодні
ведемо перемовини з Apple для
забезпечення айпадами компанія хвилі
пакар Тоді за організація USA інститут
теж це системна робота щодо забезпечення
саме девайсами для
дистанційної освіти для онлайн-освіти
формування певних певних навчальних
матеріалів всередині цих девайсів і
серед іншого можна сказати що нам
компанія Google надала безкоштовний
розширений доступ до інтернет-сервісу
Окрім цього Microsoft надав нам 1 млн
ліцензій для Microsoft Office 365 Avon і
тобто у стриманий оптимізм в цьому є
Україна не залишається позаду від цих
проблем і освітній процес був в надійних
руках наших освітян я пишаюсь нашими
освітянами Дякую ми теж дякуємо вам за
ваш час п міністр Сергій шкарлет міністр
освіти та науки України був з нами в
ефірі